five at four this is eight news now for
our parent company nextar's founders day
we chose three non-profits to bring
attention to and anchor Kirsten Joyce
we'll take a closer look right now at
how donations change the lives of
seniors in our community Through Helping
Hands of Vegas Valley
I've worked at 43 years at the Flamingo
Clara Blackwell retired from work 13
years ago to help raise her three
grandchildren one went to college and I
have two more
what is in the 12th grade and the other
one is in the eighth grade it hasn't
been easy on a fixed income she needed
help which she found through Helping
Hands of Vegas Valley help enhance
assistant with food
sometime
um
they would have clothing on there oh
this is chicken all right everything has
gone up and when you're on a fixed
income it's hard to make ends meet and
so it helps out tremendous there are
five programs through Helping Hands to
assist the less fortunate in our
community the the pantry program which
benefits clients like Clara helps
seniors age 60 and over with deliveries
to their home we know that we can't
sustain the entire month but we're
hoping that we can at least provide some
sort of relief when it comes to food and
paper products each month volunteers
bring more than 20 pounds of
non-perishable food and 10 pounds of
fresh produce to each of the seniors
throughout all of our programs we do
need funding because we have seniors
that we would like to get off the
waitlist we want to be able to serve
more seniors they also need volunteers
like Clara who while on the receiving
end has been paying it forward for the
past decade volunteering at Helping
Hands of Vegas Valley in a place that
gives you you want to give back and I
would continue to give back as long as I
can
Helping Hands of Vegas Valley also
offering respite care Transportation
home repair and nutrition programs such
great work by all the volunteers from
here at Channel 8 you might have seen
investigator Kyle Payne in the
background there as Kirsten was working
so we thank everyone here for their work
and of course all the donations you can
still make online on eightnewsnow.com
all over onto Volunteers in the
community as well and like you said all
the people who have donated already so
great work great day to give back and
don't go anywhere we will have more on 8
news now at five o'clock with Brian
Loftus and myself